j'ai invité doc gynéco pour un dîner de
boulot comme vous le savez voilà c'est
un dîner qu'il est bien passé et c'est
vite partir en cacahuète
à aucun moment tu tu es doutais que ça
doit être une caméra cachée jusqu'à un
moment je m'énerve après un mec qui te
semble un peu bah oui fois c'était
incroyable incroyable
regardez doc gynéco c'est parti c'est
impératif
tu as des idées pour moi un petit peu
avec toi dans tes émissions pour qu'on
s'éclate ensemble je pense que tu vois
que le sniper de l'énergie tu doit
rigoler quoi vous offrir des casinos en
[Rires]
fait moi je suis vraiment mais vraiment
super fan de doc gynéco qui a bercé
toute mon enfance mon adolescence pour
se dire maintenant je te dis sont aussi
je mange musique je vais musique je me
suis toujours dis que tu pourrais poser
sur un besson ce serait un truc de
malade instruit avec que des voix des
trucks a pour sa part clairement cool
mais je pourrais du foot demandé qu'on
porte à un compromis
guy m'a jamais rappelée fiori marc
demers appelez moi j'étais sur un projet
de ouf avec garou le général et non plus
donc
couchepin comme oratoire
tombant j'espère qu'elle se sait pas si
ces combats venaient me désole la bêtise
merci à toi ça te fait dans un truc toi
ouais
après les automatismes c'est ça quand
j'ai commencé avec ses rites
après ça pendant que tu connais son
humour c h oeur je reviens juste parce
que je suis en fait ce thème avec ma
cuisine ces accrocs une femme
ouf de toi regarde chaque djinékou à
bosser ensemble tient bien voir le docte
il est trop fait bon faire une petit à
petit dans un iphone
sa cousine ouest va causer la connais tu
veux pas lui faire c'est mon coeur est
beau merci tu manges à tous où tu veux
pascal ou non non c'est juste pour
attirer ton attention cache un prêt
c'est juste j'ai senti que j'avais en
suède histoire de combat par exemple
c'est moi je suis un plan de jeu jouit
qui
merci à jouer certains j'ai désolé
[Musique]
mais
je te dit avery disque rigole pas dans
l'émission ça je suis pas à ma gauche
c'est comme apôtres c'est à dire ils me
suivent dans mes des liens c'est à dire
un truc toi tu vas galerie tu va s'en
servir
j'aime bien ne pas me mettre en avant
pour moi parce que je vous aime déranger
vous déranger
[Musique]
ces engins mais la donne et les services
et c'est tout regardez jamais dérangé
j'ai voulu faire jouer les oies deux
garçons et 70 je vous dis attention au
fond c'est gentil en vue pour outrage
bientôt musique avec ça ne sera pas trop
[Rires]
ma gueule et ça se vend tout le monde il
est gentil avec toi tu es venu faire une
photo de photos c'est bon c'est pas la
peine de faire l'euro ça c'est pas c'est
pas la peine
eurostar et comme tu viens tu viens de
passer les coûts trop voir tous les
atouts de son côté
quand je chante
si vous êtes content vous êtes contente
ça va la télé tout ça c'est bon ou pas
chaud du show aux berrichons quelque
chose pour iphone et du show on a une
équipe du show tout de suite c'est rien
c'est fou c'est ce qui se passe est
assez souple un monsieur qu'est ce qui
s'est passé c'est lui les agresser ne
sait pas on se bat en direct d'accord
c'est lui nous agressent d'accord
wauquiez sont agressés t'es sérieux
souffler la bougie
[Musique]
c'est bon c'est bon c'est bon c'est bon
c'est bon c'est bon c'est mon prochain
soit bien se fasse a réagi mais qu elle
a fait pas réagi nicolas bazire
et deux minutes on vous a posé une
question de merde basé leurs actes
invite au toit ça fait d'offre monsieur
donc j'y vais comme ciudad vous allez
nous suivre aussi au commissariat on
sait tous la position apple moyen
d'accords bouleversé au peuple d'accord
non d'essayer des cdc comme on va
commencer mon jeu le malaise est obligé
de vous même noté
mouais c'est la procédure on a des
armements parce qu'on a énormément c'est
comme ça à 21,92 demain qu'un retour
avec tous les individus comme historien
commissariat
[Musique]
confiez vous prendre en charge
non je me suis dit c'est un film je me
suis dit c'est vrai après le hsa film
après c'est vrai j'ai rien compris
séries tu savais pas de véritable enfer
ça promet déjà des caméras qui sont là
question
j'ai mis mon choix c'est ça suffit basta
soir rappelle le docteur toi à 6,3
calme-toi là mais non je n'avais gestion
du pont du las et j'ai fait ça aussi
c'est un look est sur mac est donc tu à
ton tour assieds toi qu'est-ce qui se
passe mais si je nous comptons une
audition bonjour quoi les sourds treyer
vous on va prendre votre déposition
juste savoir ce qui s'est passé est ce
que vous êtes sous l'emprise de
stupéfiants ou comment vous êtes sûr de
ce que vous dites certes ok donc qu'est
ce qui s'est passé alors accéléré parce
qu'on va pas y passer la nuit un mois
pas que ça à foot quoi pardon nous
avions rendez vous avec cyril pour cyril
c'est monsieur hanouna peut-être oui
quelle gare de relations verrai avec
monsieur nenê interne ennemi intime
c'est quoi ici à une forme de respect
pour lui il est
vous savez qu'il a des démêlés avec la
justice en ce moment pardon d'accord non
quand on subit on était sur le plateau
de tournage et on a s'est rendu dans un
restaurant à peine 500 mètres plus loin
environ
ouais de là on a commencé à discuter
rigoler un peu nous prendre pour des
cons parce que là tu tourne autour du
pot nous on s'en fout là tu vois on n'a
pas que ça à faire nous on devrait
rentrer pas kosovo histoire d'un pseudo
stars là il y avait deux personnes sur
la table à la table d'à côté qui nous
ont qui vous ont ils nous ont
parfaitement reconnue
graduellement ça commençait à monter
première fois qu'on a les embrouilles
avec amina donc on aimerait bien savoir
qui c'est quoi comment et et bien ils
ont considéré qu'on leur offre et de
plusieurs individus dans un restaurant
parisien selon nos informations à ça il
serait actuellement entendues dans les
bureaux de la police judiciaire et
d'écouter ses premières réactions des
habitants les nommeurs des reines
franchement je sais pas ce qui s'est
passé s'est passé hyper vite j'étais en
train de dîner avec une copine et là on
a brûlé on
on gagne pas je me retrouve comme ça
dégoûté alors qu'est ce qui s'est passé
réellement lendemain il ya eu des tonnes
de renversant il ya une bagarre où s'est
déroulée cette altercation cette bagarre
vous nous entendez est ce qu on peut
avoir des précisions sur ce qui s'est
passé ce soir non mais vous allez tomber
car j'ai reconnu quelqu'un de loin
employer quelqu'un malgré quatre
restaurants et cantines
mais est-ce que vous avez une idée de
qui a commencé qui a démarré si c'est
plutôt doc gynéco si c'est plutôt à
cyril hanouna c'est plutôt les gens qui
se trouvaient avec eux alors et que ce
soit doc gynéco qui porté les premiers
coups diédhiou qui me ok donc maintenant
on va écrire tout ça donc qu'est-ce qui
s'est passé réellement au pied
visiblement photo a bien commencé
c'est toi qui a tapé sait ce qu'il dit
et bien c'est difficile c'est quoi ce
sait qui a monté le ton qui a tapé est
ce que c'est vous ou est-ce que c'est
monsieur hanouna personnes à taper à
personne at avait donc vous êtes là vous
êtes descendus d'un arbre de noël c'est
sain plus ou moins
ah non si c'est pas monsieur hanouna
c'est vous à moins que ce soit le père
noël de tout à l'heure il n'ya pas quoi
il n'a pas il a simplement il ya eu
c'est tout simplement des des gestes
brusques ou ya quelqu'un qui l'a poussé
il n'est pas tombé tout seul le gard non
mais tu sais quoi
à peine le témoin faisons la
confrontation genre tu m'avais dit le
témoin toi moi je demande qu à vous
croire de telles affaires sacré alain
bonjour monsieur est ce que vous
connaissez des personnes ou pas oui vous
vous reconnaissez six personnes ça c'est
sûr ok donc on vous écoute monsieur on
écoutera des accès au restaurant
ben moi j'étais tranquille avec un
copain je reconnais à monsieur gynéco
ouais on lui demande des conseils et ils
m'envoient chili sous de ma gueule mon
pote
il n'a pas apprécié et est ce qui s'est
passé mais céline a saisi m'a saisi le
bras
[Musique]
l'une des claques
maintenant je faisais frapper vous
reconnaissez ah non jamais non non on
n'a pas les couilles à un mec qui est à
l'hôpital avec de co2 paie t il n'y a
pas eu de cours
faut arrêter de me prendre pour un con
là haut tu me regarde toi je te parle
il ya eu des bousculades et la personne
a trébuché
ouais c'est ça elle a glissé sur une
peau de banane nature soit avec tout
comme super u à venir chercher tu me
ramènes autres oui
ouais tu fais sortir suis là et tu me
ramènes l'autre non mais pourquoi
mais non mais pourquoi non mais dites la
vérité
à un moment il faut arrêter c'est alors
c'est vous je n'aime les protégés par
les médias je le sais il a déjà eu des
démêlés que la justice dit qu ouais il
est régulièrement ici un l'abonnement il
a sans badge d'entrée mais répondait
monsieur gossio sans vous l'aviez en
comparution immédiate demain matin non
alors écrivez le mais non ce n'est pas
ce qui s'est passé au tout début
vous êtes arrivés ils font quoi qu'est
ce qui se passe c'est que je n'y vois
que s'ils sont énervés jeux sexuels mais
il prend vous l'emmenez à l'hosto là et
vous maniez hanouna messieurs gynéco
tout le monde sait que c'est un sale
bâtard d'accord réagissez
rien ici pensez vous laisser vous dit
que c'est une non dit que 16e je crois
j'ai médias c'est vous monsieur mayer
ceo quoi c'est bon qu'est ce qui est bon
ou mono tâche est encore en retard dont
[Musique]
les deux rôles où ils sont nuls en pd2
relou ouais je sais pas ce que c'est
drôle
monsieur hanouna je sais ce soit nous
menace il est passé à quoi il est comme
ça je vous demande qui à café
[Musique]
c'est lui c'est lui qui la poussa oui
bah vous ne dites rien
il a donc serré pas rendu compte voilà
la question est ce que vous êtes sous
l'emprise de stupéfiants à l'heure
actuelle non non non non mais vous vous
savez qu'il y avait but est dans le vert
vous le savez qu'il ya des voitures qui
nous ont copiés moi s'il vous plaît
l'alpa drame c'est une histoire loufoque
pour rien
vous seriez monsieur gynéco qui c'est
qui a tapé
je me suis pas rendu compte mais avance
non mais vous vous rendez vous pas le
surestimer
vous avez un problème de langage ou quoi
là c'est lui qui lui si c'est pour nous
ok
donc c'est vous oui monsieur gynéco vous
allez être déféré au parquet demain
matin en bon vivre c'est la nuit au
coffre vous couvrirez ce que je peux
faire de plus les clés pour monsieur une
alarme des mélodies c'est moi qui a la
clé
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
[Musique]
m